[Music]
a daily battle is being fought by more
sri lankans the battle to make ends meet
prices are rising so fast many are
wondering how they will feed their
families i'm working now where the
terror is not enough for us because all
the things up
gone up
prices are too high usually i buy 500
grams of each vegetable now it's just
250 grams
unsustainable debt reduced tourism
income and mismanagement and corruption
by the government has created sri
lanka's worst economic crisis in memory
the shortage of fuel is only adding to
the misery
it is difficult with the diesel problems
things are more expensive because of
this there are less people shopping
because many are still in fuel cues so
the vegetables don't sell and we have to
throw them away
with food so expensive people are being
forced to compromise the quantity has
come down than what it was
so and even the quality wise you buy the
cheaper stuff then the expensive
pensioners are badly affected with their
money buying far less
we normally don't cook at home
you see what we do is that we come and
buy something from a
restaurant and then go and take one
packet of lunch and then share
you see wife and mine
so
the living of this country is very
difficult
balancing their reducing purchasing
power with the need to put nutritious
meals on the table is one of the biggest
challenges facing sri lankans amid this
economic crisis that's a fact that prime
minister and acting president ranil
vikrama singha says he's hoping to
address
speaking to an international panel on
preventing global hunger and famine he
revealed the extent of the problem
the global crisis
and an internal crisis both
have come together
and
uh brought us
to a level where
many estimate as much as six million
are
facing
malnutrition
other reports which i have even say
seven and a half million vikrama singha
has admitted sri lanka is bankrupt
so whoever parliament votes in as a
successor to gotab rajapaksa will have
to solve the country's economic crisis
before it becomes a humanitarian one
miner fernandez al-jazeera colombo
sri lanka is appealing to friendly
countries for help with its flagging
economy india has extended a new credit
line worth 55 million dollars for
fertilizer imports china has announced
assistance worth 73 million dollars for
the supply of essential goods but has
stayed silent on sri lanka's request to
defer the loan repayment
colombo is also seeking an imf bailout
package to tide over the worst economic
crisis since independence
iran ramaratni is a sri lankan member of
parliament and the former state minister
of finance he says the country needs
both short and long-term financial
support the immediate challenges are
there are full queues running into days
and days
people on the streets trying to get a
few liters of petroleum
then there were gas
shortages cooking gas shortages and then
pharmaceuticals food and fertilizer
if you were to quantify you need about
roughly about
400 million dollars a month on full and
about another 100 to 150 million dollars
on gas pharmaceuticals food and
fertilizer so this is where assistance
is needed through maybe supplies credits
and also friendly countries
actually existing that is to take care
of the immediate issues on the streets
in colombo
the economic issue is much wider as
there is a discussion with the imf i
think with the new government in place
next week i would expect to sign an
agreement a staff level agreement with
the imf within weeks that would be the
beginning of actually trying to turn
things around
i think the impact of the imf is
certainly not instant it's more
long-term it will give a signal to the
market because we have been cut away
from the debt markets and then actually
to get an imf program approved by the
imf board it might take several months
but this is only the beginning so
meanwhile we have to appeal
we are working towards an extended fund
facility retirement but we have to
appeal for more emergency funding once
we have got the staff level agreement in
place